For over 100 years, Hertz has been
one of the most recognizable names
in the car rental business.
♪ Let Hertz put you in the driver's seat ♪
Nobody has more of what it takes
to get you into a new LTD
or other fine car faster.
♪ Hertz's superstar ♪
But just like their
superstar spokesperson,
Hertz wold eventually
come to a complete halt.
The short version is Corona virus hits,
nobody's traveling, and
they went into bankruptcy.
The long version is, they
were as badly prepared
for something like this as
a company could possibly be.
It's almost every step of the way,
if you were to say here's
what not to do for a company,
it almost feels like
Hertz did exactly that.
It's just sort of one
flameout after another,
one missed step after another.
Did they not understand how
fragile this company was?
This is the story of how
a company prioritized
shareholders over stability
and paid the price once catastrophe hit.
Coincidentally, the company
that would become Hertz
was started in the middle
of another pandemic.
In 1918, during the
Spanish Influenza outbreak,
a businessman named Walter Jacobs
started a car rental business in Chicago
with just 12 Ford Model Ts.
Six years later, the
company grew to 600 cars.
That's when John Hertz, then
head of the Yellow Cab Company,
would be the first to acquire the company
and rename it to the
Hertz DRIV-UR-SELF System.
After that, Hertz's ownership
would exchange hands
quite a lot, from companies
like General Motors,
RCA, and eventually Ford.
But during this time, the
company saw a ton of growth.
The rise of Hertz in, in the
1930s, 40s, 50s, and beyond
coincides with the era of
increased work traveling,
plane traveling, across the world.
Hertz, for example, in the early days,
it's able to put one of its
car lots at a Chicago airport,
so that's really helpful for them.
They move into this area
where people are going
to be getting off of
planes and immediately want
to rent a car to drive to the hotel,
drive to their business meeting.
And they're also able to
expand internationally as well.
It really kind of became
the name in rental cars.
They really were the first company
to grow big time doing this.
And they were very popular
with business customers,
so it was seen as aspirational
brand for the guy getting
off the plane in his business
suit with a briefcase
and hopping into a car after
he left the Hertz counter.
I know it's a commodity business,
but it's an iconic brand.
In the 1970s, Hertz would look
to advertise their speed of service.
And in order to do this,
they turned to a professional
athlete who, at the time,
embodied speed.
They're giving him the chance!
Now there he goes!
O.J. Simpson has broken what seemed
to be an insurmountable barrier!
At the time, O.J. was an American hero.
He was this great form of football player.
He was an actor.
He was in some of the "Naked Gun" movies.
Nordberg!
Hiya, buddy!
Hey!
Doc says I should be on my feet
and as good as new in a week!
People absolutely loved the guy.
Hertz kind of got him at
the peak of his popularity.
Others claim to be fast,
but nobody has more to do it faster,
more pros to execute the
toughest performance standards.
Hertz's relationship with O.J. lasted
from 1975 to the mid-90s.
But while the company would continue
to advertise their speed and efficiency,
they would have new competition.
Enterprise, a privately-owned
car rental company,
known more for their
locations within cities,
began expanding into airports.
The whole Hertz-O.J. connection,
much like O.J.'s life,
had this ignominious end where
the same year that he was
in the highway chase in this
white Ford Bronco, trying
to evade the police and figure
out what he's going to do
while he's being chased in
connection with the death
of Nicole Brown Simpson,
Hertz also lost their top
position for, for market share
in the US to Enterprise.
So O.J.'s no longer this American hero.
Hertz is no longer the rental king.
And it all kind of happens all at once.
And the down slide for the company,
sort of in earnest, started right there.
Hertz may have lost the
crown to Enterprise,
but by the mid-2000s, it was
still bring in tidy profits
for their parent company, Ford.
Ford was a company in trouble
to please its shareholders.
It really wanted to focus
in on its core business,
which is of course cars.
And so then you get Ford selling Hertz
to this private equity group.
In 2005, the company
would again change hands
to two private equity firms,
and Merrill Lynch and Co's buy-out unit,
for about $15 billion.
But losing Ford as an
owner had a big impact
on a core part of Hertz's business,
where they got their vehicles.
They basically churn automobiles.
They buy cars.
They rent them for some period of time,
three months, six months.
They make money off of that.
And then they hope to sell them
for more than the resale
value as in the market.
While owned by Ford,
Hertz would receive excess
cars from its parent company
at a considerable discount.
Many of these cars were
known as program cars,
where the manufacturer would
agree to buy back the car
at a certain rate of depreciation.
But once they were no
longer part of the company,
Ford would often demand a
higher price for each vehicle.
We were then forced
to buy cars under what
was called our own risk.
And that completely changed
the nature of fleet management
and the profit model in
the rental car industry.
This is Maryann Keller.
She's an automotive industry analyst
and a former board member
for Dollar Thrifty,
another car rental company
that will become important
a little later on in Hertz's story.
Suddenly, you really had
to buy cars carefully,
even to the color of the car.
Because you were really looking
at not just what you paid
for the car, but what you were
going to realize on that car
when it came out of service.
The new private equity
firm would also kick off
another, ultimately fatal trend at Hertz,
taking on debt.
The Hertz transaction
was valued at 15 billion.
But only 5.6 billion of
that was paid in cash,
the rest was paid by
saddling Hertz up with debt,
a trend that, over the
next decade-and-a-half,
would continue.
One of the first things this
private equity group did
was take out a $1 billion dividend.
And what that means is that
they're able to use the returns
that are able to
shareholders and make it look
like there're more
profits coming from Hertz,
make it a more viable investment,
and it also allows them to take on debt
to do more mergers and acquisitions.
To navigate the company under this new,
private equity ownership,
Hertz hired Mark Frissora
to be the new CEO.
Frissora is a pretty charismatic guy.
He was an acquirer. He was a negotiator.
He's a bit of a character.
He's also a deal guy.
Frissora would go on
to have many successful
years managing Hertz,
including through the financial crisis
where Hertz's stock would
fall as low as $5.35 a share
before recovering to a high point
of over $100 a share under Frissora.
The stock price went up
during Frissora's time
because of what, what, honestly,
we would call over promising
and essentially under delivering.
But the under delivering side,
the market found out later.
At the time, it was just big promises
that the market believed.
So he's very, very focused on
the financials of the company
because this is what the
shareholders care about.
But Mark Frissora, over
his tenure of Hertz,
makes a lot of mistakes.
There was significant
underinvestment in the business.
And what we mean by that is
that there was underinvestment
in the fleet.
Usually car rental companies
will refresh their fleet
almost every year.
And in Mark Frissora's time,
there was a year or two
where they just delayed
refreshing their fleet.
And what that did was that it
lowered the depreciation rate
in their PNL, which means
that they were over earning
in order to hit certain
Wall Street targets.
Such accounting practices
would prompt the SEC
to file complaints against
Hertz and Frissora.
Because the first year that you own a car,
that's when you see the
biggest depreciation.
And that depreciation, that
lowered value in the car,
you have to put that into
your financials as a cost.
So it looks bad, so instead
of buying a bunch of new cars,
he just keeps the cars for longer
so he doesn't have that cost.
The SEC complaint against him
also said that he had asked
some of his employees to make money appear
when it looked like his
financials would miss estimates
for the various earnings.
Hertz and Frissora would eventually settle
with the SEC without admitting
or denying any wrongdoing.
Hertz declined comment for the story
and Frissora didn't return
a request for comment.
A spokesperson for the former
CEO said previously that,
"Hertz's 2015 earnings
restatements have no bearing
on the company's current
financial situation,
and that Frissora didn't
direct any improper accounting
or engage in any wrongdoing."
But the decision to keep
cars in the fleet longer
did have an effect on its core customers.
Given the fact that hertz
was the dominant player
in the corporate travel market,
that was a huge risk.
Because you don't put
a traveling executive
in a car with 50,000 miles on
it that squeaks and smells.
You just don't. And that's what he did.
The other thing that
happened during Frissora
was they moved the headquarters
from New Jersey to Florida.
And 85% of the staff, the corporate staff,
didn't show up, meaning
that they didn't move
with the company.
They had to rehire a lot of people.
Hertz would find itself
carrying a lot of debt
at this point, and a large
portion of that coming
from its acquisition of the car
rental brand Dollar Thrifty.
Now, he wanted to buy Dollar
Thrifty for most of the time
that I was director.
It started when we had
financial troubles in 2007-8,
when there was a collapse
in the used-car market,
there was a collapse in the economy.
But negotiations didn't
go well for Frissora.
It was chaos. It was chaos.
He had an opportunity to buy the company
at, I think, $54 a share.
We had been telling him
that unless he would increase the price,
he would not buy it.
He refused to listen to us.
Hertz's initial offer was rejected.
And it kicked off a bidding
war with Avis Rent-A-Car.
At the same time, Dollar
Thrifty was able to
successfully navigate the recession,
helping drive up its own price.
We knew that we were the
last bite at the apple.
We knew that we were running as profitably
as anybody in the business.
He could have had the
company for something like,
I think, $54 a share.
And he eventually paid 87.50.
We were very profitable, very profitable.
Ultimately, Hertz would spend $2.6 billion
on the acquisition.
However, it would quickly
also run into costly issues
with integration.
They had a really hard time
integrating the two companies.
Things like they had two
different computer systems.
They couldn't get the
computer systems to talk
to each other.
If you're doing a buyout of a company,
if you're merging two companies,
this is a very simple thing,
it usually isn't a big headache,
but in this case it was.
According to two people
familiar with the matter,
the merger that was supposed to save Hertz
100 million a year ended up costing them
70 million in the first year.
And, in 2014, the
company would find itself
with $16 billion worth of debt.
And what bothered me, obviously,
was the fact that we were being blamed for
what was likely to happen
in terms of their earnings.
And so I spoke to a friend of mine
who had contacts in
the Icahn organization.
And I said, do you think we
should have dinner with him
and just raise this subject with him?
Carl Icahn is very well known
as this activist investor.
So when he likes a company, he'll come in
and change it for the better,
and make their stock price rise.
And that's how he makes his money
when he does things like this.
Carl Icahn has purchased roughly
an 8.48% stake in Hertz.
Carl Icahn pops up with a filing
saying he's taken a large stake
and seeking to make
changes at the companies.
There's a lot going on there.
This is a classic acquisition for Icahn.
It's a company that has a
great brand, it's well-known,
but kind of fallen on hard times.
And he thinks he can
come in and fix it up.
He essentially forced Frissora out.
Hertz CEO and Chairman Mark Frissora
is stepping down from the company.
Rather than hire
the former Dollar Thrifty
CEO, Scott Thompson,
to run the company, Icahn
went with John Tague,
an ex COO of United Airlines.
Tague definitely inherited
a company in a mess.
He has to deal with the SEC
accusations against Hertz.
He has to deal with
integrating the two companies.
And part of what he tried to
do was to update the fleet,
because, again, the
strategy of Hertz had been
to let some of these cars get old.
Hertz would find new,
even more creative ways
to take on debt.
Often leasing cars through
a subsidiary company
as asset backed securities.
But Hertz would also end
up buying cheaper sedans
rather than the more popular SUVs,
and their customers noticed.
By 2017, John Tague would retire
and new CEO Kathryn
Marinello would inherent
13.5 billion in debt.
When Marinello takes over
she has a lot of problems
to deal with.
She's got this fleet of
cars that people don't want.
And she's got an old reservation system
that wasn't working well.
So she spends a lot of money
in a very short amount of
time to fix that system
and to upgrade the fleet of cars there,
and offer people what they really want.
She is doing the right things.
She's helping to reduce some of the debt.
She's getting customers back to Hertz.
The cars are starting to look better,
but there's a question of
could she ever have fixed
Hertz in the state it was in
or did it just require more time?
But Hertz never got that time.
The deadly coronavirus,
officially hitting the US.
As the world grapples
with the deadly outbreak,
people have grown anxious
about being in crowds
or traveling in confined
spaces like airplanes.
So the pandemic hits and
all the rental car companies
have these lots at
airports and on main drags
all over the country,
just packed with cars.
This is a big problem in
a rental car business,
you just can't get rid of
vehicles really quickly.
So we have nobody renting the cars,
so money isn't coming in.
And then you have to go
to these bond holders,
who want to be paid 100% in full.
So that gets them in a
place where they eventually
have to declare bankruptcy,
because they just didn't
have enough cash on hand
to pay back the people who
lent them all that debt.
Hertz's Chapter 11 petition
would show the company would
have over $24 billion in debt
and only a billion of cash on hand.
Kathryn Marinello would resign as CEO
a week before filing bankruptcy.
And Carl Icahn would eventually sell
his entire stock in the company,
losing an estimated $1.6 billion.
Carl's got a lot of money,
he's a legitimate billionaire,
but even for him that
was a catastrophic loss.
It does seem like Hertz can survive this.
Maybe it will be a much smaller company
when it does survive this,
maybe the structure of Hertz,
and the way its debt looks,
and the people who own Hertz
will look very different,
but, again, remember
there aren't that many
car rental agencies.
So it still has that brand recognition.
I think that hurts could
have been turned around
with different management.
Management that was really
interested in building
a solid business and getting rid of some
of that corporate debt that they had,
because that made them more
vulnerable than anybody else.
You know, it's astonishing.
That's the Achilles heel.
If you look at what Frissora
did and what Icahn did,
they did very different
things to the company,
but the common thread with both of them
is they wanted really good
quarterly results fast.
There is some, I think,
sort of sense of irony
that they take on this marketing approach
that's just running as fast as they can,
and, by the end, Hertz
has a ton of baggage
and tried to grow really fast
through some tactics that
didn't end up serving it well.